yeah walked around Osaka took them to
like the Pokemon Center there thoughts
on body because they were like they
wanted to buy stuff for like nephews and
stuff and dude there was a line of like
200 people to buy stuff something at
this awesome of course there would be
yeah yeah
um because I have like Regional [__]
right yeah yeah and I took them to a
there was a retro arcade and I was like
you should come you should check out
some retro arcade I thought they weren't
gonna like it much but my dad was he was
just playing Gallagher for like an hour
yeah
I was like okay I can still play Metal
Slug until he's done I was I was like
I'm chill with this I guess I'm chill
out it's just crushing it over here yeah
yeah yeah I took him to Osaka Castle
which is probably my favorite touristy
thing that I did mostly the castle was
kind of sick I I a lot of the touristy
stuff in Japan I either haven't done or
have done and thought it was kind of meh
yeah because a lot of it's super
overrated or super Rams um but also like
a castle actually the view from it was
really cool and all the historical stuff
uh was uh really cool and quite quite
interesting although there was like two
floors of the castle which you weren't
allowed to photograph
and I don't know why that I'm wondering
what the rules are behind this but this
dude had the worst job ever he had a
giant no photography sign and whenever
anyone tried to take a photo or whipped
it out he would scream and run across
telling no photo no photo and I can't I
just imagine myself like man what a [__]
job yeah it's just every tourist known
to man your job is to figure out what
goddamn language to shout at them in
people are gonna take photos yeah
they're just gonna do it like is this
just how it is and you make me think
like what is the what is the thought
process behind not like that guy impact
ain't getting paid enough man dude
nowhere near enough but also polyglot
goes to the efforts 12 languages and he
gets that job you've got to figure out
like you're like damn I think you just
defaulted to English on everyone yeah I
don't understand why they we couldn't
take pictures of it because Miniatures
of the castle Yeah I was just in my head
I'm like I I don't I don't know like
people are gonna take pictures like
crazy of course I don't know if I'm just
being like a cynical I'm like maybe we
should just let him take pictures I mean
Japan's rules concerning like no
photography is like it can be quite
agreed it's confusing because it's just
only those two floors yeah but the view
from the castle is amazing uh if you
ever get the chance to go to Osaka I
mean I'd recommend it I'd it was great
yeah yeah I I normally I I never do the
touristy stuff I think it's so lame
um but this one actually was it's
probably the best view of all soccer as
well you get such a cool panoramic view
the whole uh whole city also Osaka a
really fun city yeah yeah so
um I took them to at night I took them
body and they were like yeah I guess
I've seen it at movies before they were
kind of underwhelmed by it they're like
yeah I guess it's kind of cool I mean I
guess yeah it is just just lights in it
yeah I get it they weren't impressed by
the giant [__] crab mechanical thing
that they have and like one of the crab
stores oh we didn't go past that one oh
you didn't know we walked along the
river yeah yeah yeah
um and uh yeah then then we went out to
drinking and it was fun I mean all
second people were pretty fun yeah I
think I went to the one bar
those should only foreigners by accident
uh Hub like we went out of this cocktail
bar and I thought sick dude I found a
sick cocktail bar yeah and so we walk in
and there's just like one of the tourist
person in there yeah so in the time
we're drinking or one drink the entire
Place fills with tourists yeah and I was
like damn this not that there's anything
wrong with that because I would I mean
technically you wanted to give him like
a Japanese I was like I don't want to
find them a cool spot and I thought I
found a cool spot yeah but obviously I
don't live in Osaka and then of course I
just found the one where it's [__]
everyone every goddamn tourist found
yeah
um but then I found this really cool
like if you're looking I I got this this
ad for this part it looks so weird and I
was like dude we should I was like I
don't know if we should go but our
friend Eugene was like we should go but
I was kind of like I don't know so it
was called a Magic Bar okay that sounds
like a very Eugene thing yeah so then
here's the deal here's the deal so we
found it right I saw it and I was like I
don't know yeah and then his story is
like we should go check it out and I'm
like yeah
go it's in like literally on the Alley
that has just all of the sex stuff yeah
right and
um it's on like the fifth floor of a
really dirty ass building
you know and it's like one of like six
bars on this fifth floor of this tiny
building so there's like Max five seats
and the thing is and this is what had me
worried was that if you sit down on this
Magic Bar you had to sit there for 70
minutes because you're paying for 70
minutes of magic regardless oh okay yeah
so he does a little show for you yeah
you drink and it's like okay like the
bartender is a magician and it was like
3500 Yen each per person to sit down and
the bartender is a magician yeah now I I
was like I this could be either the best
thing ever or just the weirdest thing
ever yeah and so he's like we should
check it out I'm fine fine I'll check it
out I'll I'll and again I'm the vibe
check I have to go in see if they're
cool with a white guy walking in and you
know even though I'm talking you know
and I was I'll explain to Eugene I'm
like listen there's like QuickTime
events the first three sentences matter
so much in these bars you have to nail
every interaction in Japanese for them
to be comfortable if you don't have
communication 100 yeah all the first
three questions they'll ask you are the
first three sentences because otherwise
they'll get super nervous and they'll be
like actually no don't sit down sorry
we're reserved or yeah one of the
excuses right so you need to nail it and
I'm like oh God I hate I hate doing this
because like it's just annoying because
then I I'm like I talk to them and then
I'm like here are my very foreign people
with me you know because if it's me and
then it's like everyone else looks
Japanese it's kind of easier yeah yeah
you know but if I'm gonna be the
translator and sometimes and also like
this is a different dialect as well yeah
I don't understand what they're saying
and it's kind of awkward but anyway we
go in this bar and there's no one in
here and it looks like a just a normal
ass weird bar yeah it was just like it's
just a bar with a bunch of random stuff
in it sure and uh he seems kind of
interesting this guy and he was called
like oh [__] I had the business card oh
he has a magic name he has a magic name
but it's his name but magic in front of
it so it's his surname white Magic Mike
Magic Mike and we walk in and the guy's
like kind of friendly yeah uh a little
bit precarious at first but then he kind
of warms up and he's like okay cool like
you're okay with the he was he explained
the rule again that we read on the
Google that was like yeah are you cool
with the 300500 yeah I don't wanna like
you know yeah it's fine yeah
and so he's kind of getting ready he
makes his a drink and then he he like
he's like here play with this thing and
he puts like this thing the useless box
have you seen this thing before that's
where you push it and then the thing
comes out and just pushes it back yeah
oh yeah it's like this and I was like oh
God this is it is this like the vibe
while he's getting ready just gives us
this and he tells my mum to just push it
forward and I'm like okay man Push It
Forward I should just presses it
downwards and obviously nothing happens
because you should just push forward
yeah like mum Push It Forward how do you
[__] up that one thing you have to
anyway
so he's doing that and then he's still
preparing some stuff and then he comes
back out takes his useless box puts his
other thing and it's like a coffin and
you press the button and then just this
eye opens and a little thing goes
I'm like what the [__] is this bar dude
what is the concept for the Magic Bar
was like you walk in and it's like all
right poof your money is yeah
I'm like [__] this is this is uh that's
all the [__] you give to four-year-olds
to be like yeah entertain yourself you
know dude this man is really [__]
shutting the ball low yeah this is this
is weird like and then
[Music]
I guess all his shit's in there yeah so
it goes in this curtain and my my mom is
like looking terrified she's like can we
go or something I'm like no we've paid
now we have this yeah we're seeing how
the show is turning out
he just comes back in and then he's like
silently walks in like a mime and then
he just smiles and in his teeth are just
glow up teeth
oh God this is gonna be terrible this is
gonna be so bad
and then um
again goes back into the closet comes
back out and I I can't remember how this
all kicked off uh but he's uh he's he
like whips out his wallet and it's a
Louis Vuitton and he opens his wallet
and it's just it just sets Ablaze right
it's just all that's all the money that
he took from them but yeah it's like
here's your money right now it's a
euphemism this is your wallet he's doing
like two to his credit right like this
whole time he's like doing really fun
playful English like his English would
be pretty good yeah to keep my parents
engaged in Madrid and I was like oh [__]
I didn't make job being like all right
okay oh that's all my money gone all
right okay I should do the magic now and
then close this wall I don't know why I
did this then you started doing card
tricks and the card tricks are pretty
[__] good he started doing like
really good like all right is this your
card kind of thing yeah yeah it was
pretty standard stuff and it was like oh
it was pretty good all right this guy
ain't bad all right and then he started
doing these tricks
um and he slowly got better and better
so doing better tricks he's really
[__] cool and then he started doing
this thing I don't know if you've ever
seen magicians do this where they have
like two elastic bands right and they
keep somehow connecting them and
disconnect oh yes oh yes yeah and he was
nutty at it like Acts actually insane he
would get my parents to hold the elastic
band tight and close and somehow he'd
keep connecting it and disconnecting
yeah yeah and it was like okay this
guy's pretty [__] all right he's
pretty cracked and then between like
every like set of so he would do like a
bunch of different magic tricks with
like one thing and then he would kind of
like he'd be like all right who wants a
drink and then he'd make drinks and then
he would start the next kind of it was
actually pretty [__] I've already
seen those magic bars for years now I
thought they were so [__] I've always
been curious to go into it yeah yeah but
now I know I need multiple pass one one
time
we were like should we try it out and we
were just like oh it's really tempting
but it looks so stupid yeah they always
look sketchable they always charge a
massive fee for you yeah and then I'm
always like I don't know and then he did
those tricks dude it was so he was
actually [__] nuts then he started
doing like the whole
um the classic where you have like a
ring and then he keeps somehow getting
it on and off his finger with like
sleight of hands yeah yeah and then he
brought out like a rope and then a wand
and then he would somehow like you'd
have to like I don't know it was maybe
it was like basic magic but he was
really [__] good how intoxicated were
you I was not that impossible that's the
important question I mean he was he was
to his credit his acting charge was
pretty good and he was putting on a show
he was pretty funny all right and then
uh at the end he did like uh
yeah yeah he did a few tricks that were
really [__] cool I thought like he
did one way like put the like a full-on
nail like a giant nail up his nose oh
yeah did you like hammer it and stuff
and then it appeared and then like okay
is this your card and then it you know
it wouldn't be the card and to his
credit like he his acting was really
[__] good because I thought he'd
[__] up and then he just didn't [__]
up and then somehow he he he's like no
no this is a mistake this is a mistake I
have to uh a banish card and then he
starts eating the card right and then he
just like whips it out of like inside of
a pouch inside of a pouch inside of a
pouch he's like a visual card I was like
what the [__] that's so cool it was
really good it was a really good man I
think it's just literally called Magic
Bar in uh Osaka I'm sure that's what
most of them yeah check it out it was
[__] fun it was great my parents
loved it and then uh yeah that was a fun
night out in Osaka I didn't go crazy
because you know if I took him to like a
girls bar or bar we have to talk more
Japanese people it would just be me
translating for like three people and
yeah yeah like it's a lot it's
exhausting first time
it's like [__] I just want the drink of
course yeah no because you've got to
play caretaker because I did I did but I
was like how do I make experiences they
don't rely on me translating everything
because you want to have fun as well
yeah I want to not be exhausted yeah you
know sometimes I'm driving showing them
around and I'm just translating all day
and it's like oh my God it's tough yeah
you forget especially like after taking
care of people how much you just take
for granted in terms of how you know
like the way the country functions for
sure like you know when you get asked
like the littlest thing for every thing
that kind of like adds up and adds up
and adds up yeah every single time yeah
they ask me especially if your dad is
asking what beer this is
um like they had cover charge in one
place because in charge of pretty common
in Japan yeah yeah 500 to 1000 yen you
get a snack or something and my dad was
like did I did I get scammed and I was
like no no it's
it's normal but it uses on guard with
everything yeah yeah like an ATM he's
like is that ATM safe and I was like
they're all safe every ATM's safe I mean
I get where it's concerned because it's
not all safe yeah I told them I'm like
everything's safe here don't worry like
anything it's all good it's all safe no
one's trying to scam you no one's trying
to do anything Japan's probably well
like one of the countries in Asia where
you can feel most at home feeling safe
not getting scammed just stay away from
the back streets of shinjuk and shubia
you'll be good yeah yeah just don't say
yes if someone asks you to come to the
bar and you're probably like safe yeah
yeah I told them to go to saksa as well
I didn't want to go with them because I
was like this oh I was really busy
yeah I took Sid's parents there yeah
that's it yeah I mean it's like Kyoto
and just like one one little area in
Tokyo it's kind of tough because I don't
think they have much interest in temples
or stuff like that they appreciate it
but they're not like they're not they
don't really they're not seeking it yeah
I don't think you should go check it out
it's kind of interesting yeah and then
they were like what's with all this um
with all the smoke stuff I was like oh
what well again they're trying
everyone's blowing smoke on themselves
like what are you what I was like oh
they meant like when they put the
incense in the thing and then they yeah
you know yeah they kept asking me what
all the women to Kyoto they're like what
is all this stuff where they're trying
to why why do they want money I was like
so I guess God needs money I don't know
I don't know this Temple isn't paying
for itself yeah and I was like damn they
know the upkeep you know and they were
yeah they were they didn't want to get
their fortunes tons like oh we should
get up we should get our Fortune she was
told she's got unfortunately told and my
mum got bad fortune she's like this is
why I didn't want my fortune top I
always get bad fortunes and I was like
no it's fun it's fun to find it you
remind me because we I did the same
thing with like Sid's parents as well
same thing mom mom got the bad fortune
and she was like I can't believe it of
course my fortune is bad and I'm like we
need to just tie it up then she so she
starts tying it up and she's like gonna
buy another Fortune because is is that
is that part of the game and it's just I
want to be double blessed actually yeah
and I'm just like Mom you're a true
gacha gamer not right now you've
realized anything can be good luck if
you have enough money exactly so she
just kept going until she got the Good
Luck Charlie she whales for the
Grimlocks
and I'm like that's my mum